those who serve in boats like this one
call themselves the silent service
but a new nuclear-powered submarine pact
between the uk the us and australia has
triggered a noisy reaction from china
it severely damages regional peace and
stability intensifies the arms race and
jeopardizes international efforts
promoting the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons
this is a highly irresponsible act
the three partners say building a new
submarine fleet for australia and
collaborating more broadly in security
will bolster their defenses in the
indo-pacific and beyond
but it's also bruised a key ally
a french submarine contract with
australia now sunk
it is really a stab in the back we built
a relationship of trust with australia
and this trust has been betrayed and i'm
angry today and bitter about this breach
this is not done between allies
especially when there's been two years
of negotiations for this contract
at an arms fair in london the defense
secretary said he sympathized with what
he described as france's disappointment
and he dismissed chinese allegations of
the three allies having a cold war
mentality
it's a cold war allegation to say that
it's a cold war it's not a cold war this
is simply uh the exercise a country that
shares our value exercising its desire
to keep strategically one place ahead to
make sure its defenses are strong that
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing provocative
reacting to news of the deal in the
commons not everyone seems so sure what
are the implications of this pact for
the stance that would be taken by the
united kingdom and for its response
should china attempt to invade taiwan
big questions left hanging questions 2
for france also selling its wares at the
defense fair
the focus is on submarines but this new
security alliance is all about western
allies teaming up in the face of what's
seen as an existential challenge posed
by china the hope on the uk side is that
the rift with france will fade because
ultimately they share the same values
and right now western powers need to
stick together
but it's a tension that rivals like
china could well seek to exploit
debra haynes sky news